une ski merci d'être avec nous vos
livres volodymyr zelensky a montré
depuis ce matin qu'il est déterminé et
qu'il appelle son peuple à résister ils
facilitent pas la tâche du président
russe vladimir poutine en ce moment le
président ukrainien non c'est sûr mais
je dirais qu'il n'a pas d'autre issue
il ya quelque chose qui relève
effectivement d'une forme de
martyrologie et de désespoir dans son
attitude
quand on perd tout on essaye de le
perdre avec panache et c'était la raison
c'est ce qui le meut
je voudrais dire quelque chose qui va
paraître presque
léger ou primesautier mais il ya quelque
chose d'intéressant dans ce personnage
devant le nîmois zelensky qui est un
ancien acteur un ancien comique et on se
demande
dans la mesure où il remplit sa tâche
aujourd'hui vous savez qu'il avait
participé à un feuilleton une série dans
laquelle il joue est précisément le
président ukrainien bien vous
dénoncer la corruption alors ça dans la
réalité la corruption ukrainienne existe
toujours de même qu'elle existe en
russie quand vladimir poutine dénonce
l'état corrompu ukrainien on pourrait
dire que il voit la paille dans l'oeil
du voisin sans voir la poutre qu'il a
dans le sien bon ça fait partie de la
propagande marans qui re conscience et
l'inscrit à nouveau c'est l'idée que
finalement cet homme à travers son
activité passée qui était légère et
rentrer dans la peau du personnage d'un
président de la république et vous savez
très bien que les acteurs parfois
investissent tellement leurs personnages
qu'ils finissent par le par lui
ressembler
parenthèse fermée
quand vous disiez que il facilite pas la
tâche à ladignac outin et bien non bien
sûr pourquoi la faciliterait t-il
poutine qui hier proposé des
négociations sera une invasion très
rapide fulgurante et c'est pas le cas ça
va être plus compliqué visible enfin
pour l'instant oui parce que parce qu'au
fond la dernière des solutions encore
une fois c'est pour l'ukraine c'est le
panache c'est qu'on ne puisse pas dire
justement que cette nation n'existait
pas puisqu'elle c'est à elle se serait
aplati ou couchés devant l'invasion
russe ça n'est pas le cas elles existent
des gens qui sont là pour la défendre ça
ne veut pas dire que ce sont des
fascistes ça veut dire que tout
simplement une nation c'est quoi c'est
pas comme poutine le croire c'est pas
une race c'est pas du sang c'est pas la
langue une nation ce sont des gens qui
ont envie de vivre ensemble avec un
certain nombre d'accords de désaccord me
dire on se retrouve sur des sur une base
minimum c'est ça une nation
contrairement à ce que les nationalistes
10 et dans ce cadre là on s'aperçoit
qu'elle existe bel et bien cette nation
ukrainienne et est-ce qu'une résistance
des partisans en ukraine elle est
envisageable sont sans aide militaire
extérieure l'aide militaire extérieure
c'est probablement ce qui va ce qui
arrive déjà et ce qui va arriver
il y à l'allemagne qui est toujours
réticente dans cette affaire l'allemagne
va être va devoir revoir drastiquement
sa position mais c'est une quasiment une
révolution copernicienne pour elle le
fait de ne pas vouloir donner des armes
à l'ukraine c'est à la fois de ménager
vladimir poutine parce qu'il ya le
l'approvisionnement en gaz même si olaf
scholz a annoncé qu'il suspendu la
certification mais c'est aussi de nord
stream 2 parce qu'à part de 1 fonctionne
tout à fait exactement mais c'est aussi
ce qui marque l'histoire de l'allemagne
et qui l'allemagne moderne et
démocratique qui considèrent que plus
aucun combat ou de guerre de doit partir
de son territoire surtout en direction
des slaves que l'allemagne nazie a
particulièrement opprimés et est décimée
donc il y as est là aussi on voit le
poids de l'histoire chez poutine il faut
le voir du côté allemand et voir comment
comment ils vont réagir juste d'un point
pour parler pour finir de parler de
l'allemagne à un diplomate allemand qui
disent il ya quelque temps il n'ya pas
longtemps il ya quelques jours ça nous
paraît déjà une éternité qui disait au
fond à travers nos bonnes relations
commerciales avec la russie et la chine
nous avions l'impression que nous
jouions un rôle diplomatique
en réalité c'est tout l'inversé
nos relations de bonnes relations
commerciales avec la chine et la russie
nous ont compromis et c'est cela qu'il
faut réviser aujourd'hui vous parler du
passé de l'allemagne nazie de justement
pour l'allemagne le président ukrainien
a comparé l'invasion russe à celle de
l'allemagne nazie pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale ils se renvoient la
balle là quand même plein oui c'est un
renvoi direct oui c'est un renvoi
d'histoire mais vous savez il n'est pas
complètement
il n'est pas inné pas non pertinent
vous souvenez de ce qu'avait dit joe
biden quand il a été lui il avait
accordé une interview à une chaîne
américaine on y avait dit qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la dîmière poutine y
avait dix est un tueur on avait dit il
va fort baydan il est un peu sénile et
l'admirent poutine d'ailleurs avaient
répandu de manière assez sibylline c'est
celui qui dit y est pas et ben vladimir
poutine a parlé récemment de d'un état
nazi allons-y c'est vladimir poutine qui
dit celui qui y est c'est lui et il n'a
pas il n'a pas tort zelensky parce que
la motivation profonde vladimir poutine
c'est la défense de la race je rappelle
qu'il a justifiée entre autres cette
intervention en faisant une allusion
racialiste à l'argent russe ce que
n'avait jamais fait ni le tsarisme lit
le soviétisme ni le communisme qui ont
toujours dit qu'au fond alors c'était
largement fou mais qui ont dit que les
peuples non russe s'était associé à la
grande russie par affection et par
finalement émotion bien là la définition
qu'en donne la lumière poutine est assez
proche de la définition de la
répartition des races que faisait le
nazisme effectivement merci bon